ils sont arrivés au viol au prêcheur
traumatisé par un cyclone majeur
un couple et ses sept enfants réfugiés
chez leur arrière grand mère qui les
connaissaient pas ben j'ai vu ta est
venu m'a dit manger tout ça
cette heureuse aujourd'hui avec adama
faye voudrez bien qu'ils restent
ah oui treize mois après leur arrivée il
est dur en sont toujours dans
l'incertitude face à l'avenir
le tribunal administratif doit
prochainement statuer sur leur sort
yann et de père martiniquais et à ce
titre son avocat espère bien lui
décroché son titre de séjour nous invite
à nous patinons par les maisons d hôtes
et viège le boîtier terrain là c'est
notre dominique non pas des guerres la
wii conte à dormir là oui doctement
menotti guerra piger route et pas
concertés soit voté en famille peut-être
tout paris qui en sont en partie d un
côté on l'a pris en beauté ont révélé à
même la vinification au quotidien la
tante d'une décision de justice est
insoutenable
oui un bisou et avancer parce que ma
famille ne pas payer les enfants
perçoivent bien sous stress même s'ils
sont à l'école trois ans primaire de au
collège et l'aîné au lycée saint james
je veux rester ici parce que je suis à
l'école et d un ep tout j'aime ça j'aime
les dessins et photos sur tout ça ça va
prendre ton métier ici oui vous avez
bien l'école j'ai des fois j'ai bu au
moins j'ai 18 souvent de heathrow giroud
français et maths
les enfants se sentent chez eux dans une
commune solidaire la justice décidera de
leur avenir